vous avez du sextoy à la maison non non
c'est vrai que maintenant je vous jure
vous n'allez pas à non pourquoi elle a
déjà des soucis et n'amène à domicile à
quoi j'ai battu mon année sextoys à
laval bien sûr management n'a pas
regardé thierry non quant à nadal il en
avait bah oui cette fois vous avez quoi
bein rabbit quoi ravir et vaginales et
clitoris avait à rabbi jacob
mais comme dans sex and the city avoir
un sac ou parce que vous en avez vous
isabelle non ça on n'est jamais eu je
canard en caoutchouc quand j'étais petit
mais non sinon
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
matthieu delormeau et que tout ce qui
fait pas mais je fais tout ce qu'il faut
pas faire ils me regardent vitalité
m'interroge pas là qu'il en a vous avez
des sextoys sûr que non
j'aurai le nom vous n'avez pas norton
offrir mes oreilles quelque chose qui te
sert de sextoys n'ont pas choisi
n'importe où vous vous avez j'en avais
ras pas rapporter 1 du japon un jour ah
oui mon adn les 1 à 9 à 9
vous en êtes servis la ville en a
l'envié vous dit rouge les 1000 of union
[Applaudissements]
un jour j'étais énervé en voiture et je
les jeter sur quelqu'un le look c'est
vrai avait dû être content on tombe à
quoi assumer mais je l'avais un certain
soir c'était julien courbet un truc qui
m'a fait mourir de rire quand serena
non mais vous je voulais pas raconter
c'est bon ça on m'a offert un jour un
tel choix pour moi j'ai reçus saab sauvé
les boules dans les glaces faur pour que
vous ont des boules de geisha les boules
geographic on est supposé se mettre dans
le fondement
ouais voyeur et ben ma belle mère est
tombée dessus elle n'a pas compris que
c'est un succès mais l'ami dans le sapin
à noël
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon c'est bon ah ouais mais
j'aimerais bien passer noël avec vous et
moi le japon vous en foutez un chapeau
jean-luc alors qu'ils sont très prisés
des et la balle et le service au japon
le sexe et son tabou japon l'europe ça
s'achète partout dans la rue comme ça
s'est décomplexé complètement et j'avais
acheté ce qu'on appelait un tanga c'est
une sorte de machine qu'on ouvre à
l'intérieur c'est vide
il ya une sorte de d'imitation
indications de silicone et aux
promeneurs marchant on met son sexe n'a
t on referme et un effet vibrant
aspirants tout ce que vous voulez vous
mais vous voulez votre sexe n'ont cessé
au silicone intérieur ou et vous mettez
votre sexe dans présente à l'heure et
après ça fait son effet que met en
prison seul problème ce qui s'était
j'avais acheté au japon et on n'est pas
visiblement renfermer sur foot à moitié
ouvert va fermer la cgt un courant d'air
[Rires]
[Musique]